- [Narrator] By now,
you've hopefully finished
all of "You," season
two but if you haven't,
beware, there are spoilers ahead.
- We can be together now.
- I don't think we can.
I think I broke you.
- I'm fine.
- Listen to me,
this is not your fault, this is not you.
Everything I told you is true.
Beck, Henderson, Delilah, I killed them,
their blood is on my hands.
- Joe, you didn't kill Delilah, I did.
- [Narrator] So, who
saw that twist coming?
- [Joe] What the fuck?
- [Narrator] It turns out
Love is a better match for Joe
than he ever imagined.
- I wolf you.
- I wolf you too.
- [Narrator] The parallels between them
go all the way back to
their respective childhoods.
- We both had to learn how
to survive really young.
How old were you the first time?
- Nine.
- I'm so sorry.
- [Narrator] We hear
about Love and Forty's
rich yet troubled childhood
throughout the season.
One story we keep returning to
is about an au pair they had
when their parents set up Anavrin.
- The year my parents launched Anavrin
they left us with this
fucking crazy au pair.
Forty saw way too much too young.
The way Forty tells it,
she was his first love,
to this day he's not
acknowledge that it was abuse.
- [Narrator] When Forty
unwittingly figures out
the real story about Beck's murder,
while high on LSD,
he also tells Joe what
he believes is the truth
about the au pair.
- When I found out she was
seeing some college guy,
I felt this rage inside of me,
like an animal, made of teeth and of fire,
then I blacked out and I killed her.
I came to and I was standing over her.
- [Narrator] But, by the end,
Love tells a different story.
- Forty was a child, she
was a rapist, I stopped her.
I protected Forty because I had to,
'cause nobody else was.
(intense music)
Better they thought it was him.
Forty was blacked out, a victim.
- [Narrator] This is the first parallel
between Joe and Love.
Joe's first kill was also at a young age,
he was just nine years old
when he shot his father.
Fast forward to Joe and
Love's first meeting,
that in itself is the seasons first twist.
- [Joe] Hello, you.
No, fuck, no, I'm not doing that.
- [Narrator] Joe leads
the audience to believe
it's your standard meet queue.
- Do you think this
peach looks like a butt?
- [Narrator] That is until Joe reveals
at the end of episode one
that he's had his sights set
on Love all along.
Now, there are few people in the show
who can match Joe's level of obsession
but Love comes close.
The way she talks about her
first impressions of him
mirror the way he talks about his victims
when he first encounters them.
- And then I saw you,
I knew right away, in my gut,
I recognized something in you
and hey, smart, sexy, funny,
a little darkness that made
you less story book, more real.
I started to fantasize again.
- [Narrator] And it turns out,
she too has a little stalker in her.
- Maybe I got a little obsessed,
maybe I used my parents
means to do a little digging
after Candace left.
They owned me that much.
- This is how she discovers Joe's cage,
which doesn't freak her
out in the slightest.
- You were even smarter, more passionate,
more devoted than I'd known.
- [Narrator] Even finding
out Joe killed Beck
doesn't seem to phase her.
In fact, the way she
sees Beck mirrors the way
Joe spoke about Benji,
Beck's hipster boyfriend from season one.
- [Joe] I do understand
something about you now, Beck,
you somehow think this
guy is all you deserve.
- Guinevere Beck was
un-special and mediocre,
she didn't deserve you.
- [Narrator] Once she finds
out about this dark side,
she tried to provoke it.
In the episode "Ex-istential Crisis,"
Joe believes Love has moved on with Milo.
But to hear Love tell it,
she was using him in
an attempt to coax out
his more murdery tendencies, yikes.
- If you could trust
me, show me your heart,
even the darkest parts,
then we'd be starting our future
together on the right foot.
- [Narrator] Joe is
constantly making excuses
for his behavior,
generally claiming he
murders people for Love.
This is something Love does too,
both for him and herself.
- [Love] You did some terrible things
but that's what sensitive
people do when they're trapped
in a bad relationship.
- [Narrator] This is why, she claims,
she kills Delilah and Candace.
- [Love] I dealt with Delilah the same way
I dealt with the au pair.
I'm protecting you because I want to.
- [Narrator] Even the way
she covers up her crimes
has echos of Joe.
Watch how Love lays out
her plan to cover up
Delilah and Henderson's murders.
- We frame Ellie for Henderson's murder
with an anonymous tip.
Between the total lack of evidence
and the fact she's a 15-year-old girl,
it instantly becomes a joke.
That's when Delilah's body will be found
with a suicide note,
the shock waves will destroy the case,
Ellie will walk free with
settlement money for life.
The investigation becomes poisoned
and you are never mentioned in connection
with Henderson again.
- [Narrator] Doesn't it
sound a lot like something
Joe would come up with?
"You" is told mostly from
the prospective of Joe
and this entire twist is built around
the way he creates unrealistic versions
of the women he's obsessed with.
- You know why this is happening?
Because while I was seeing
you, really seeing you,
you were busy gazing
at a god damn fantasy.
A perfectly imperfect girl,
you saw what you wanted to see
but I was always right
here, the whole time.
- [Narrator] But if you
go back to episode two,
her dark side is definitely foreshadowed.
As Joe cuts up Jaspers body,
the scene is intercut
with Love preparing a meal
but more specifically,
cutting up a joint of meat.
Love has always been more
like Joe than he ever knew.
- We're soulmates, Joe.
- [Narrator] But is that enough for him?
The seasons ending suggests no.
He's about to kill Love when she reveals.
- No, I'm pregnant! (gasping)
- [Narrator] Joe is obsessed
with protecting children,
perhaps because of his
own troubled childhood,
so the prospect of becoming a father
is enough to save Love's life.
- Nothing is more important than this.
- [Narrator] As the season
comes to a close, however,
it's clear this isn't enough for him.
Love may be his murderous equal
but he sees suburban life
with her as a prison.
- [Joe] Not ever Siberia is cold.
Summer '73, it's sunny with
eco-conscious landscaping
and when I found myself here, locked in,
I thought this was the end.
- [Narrator] And it
seems he has his eyes set
on his next victim.
- [Joe] This is where I had to be,
exactly where I had to be to meet you.
See you soon, neighbor.